now we also have to talk about the House
and Senate we've been devoting a lot of
attention to what's going on with the
presidential race because it is so
important because of the Supreme Court
because of so much of what it means to
have 12 years of consecutive Democratic
presidents for the first time in nearly
a hundred years dating back to FDR and
Harry Truman the period starting in 1933
as I spoke about at the top of the show
let's now talk about the importance of a
Democratic president versus Democratic
control of the Senate and house
if you look at the nearly eight years of
President Obama you know that President
Obama has had to deal with some of the
most vile and obstinate Republican
obstructionism that we've seen in a very
long time and it's a sort of vicious
circle Republicans obstruct President
Obama President Obama then has to use
executive orders to get anything done
and then Republicans slammed President
Obama for using executive orders which
is necessitated by their own
obstructionism now it's still a pretty
flaccid critique because President Obama
has used fewer executive orders than his
predecessors including Republican
predecessors but as we know the low
information right-wing voters have no
idea if it sounds like a good critique
of President Obama they're going with it
so where are the Senate and House races
right now let's start with the Senate
currently 44 Democrats 54 Republicans
and two independents now the two
independents angus King and this guy
named Bernie Sanders who you may have
heard of both caucus with Democrats so
if we look at the balance of power
it's basically 54 to 46 in favor of
Republicans right now according to Nate
Silver's fivethirtyeight.com
the chance of winning control is
currently sixty eight point three
percent for Democrats and thirty one
point seven percent for Republicans and
if you look at the states here you'll
notice that there are only some states
in play here and as the numbers go
because the Vice President breaks ties
in the Senate if Hillary Clinton wins
Democrats need to gain four seats to
take control it would make it 5050 but
if there's a tie Tim Cain would break
the tie at presumably in favor of the
Democrats if Donald Trump wins Democrats
need five seats to take control to make
it 51 to 49 since presumably vice
president Mike Pence would not be on the
side of Democrats in breaking ties
that's the Senate okay now let's talk
about the House of Representatives and
this is where I'm going to talk about a
rigged election Donald Trump has been
talking about a rigged election for a
long time just this morning I was
watching a speech he gave he was meeting
with some farmers in Florida early
voting has begun in many states
including in Florida
Trump is canvassing the state and Donald
Trump was telling them you know the
polls are rigged
there's bogus polls in South Carolina he
says he was supposedly losing and he
focused a lot of time there and ended up
winning in a landslide and it's all just
completely rigged now this is totally
bogus we've debunked this before if the
election is rigged it's mostly
Republican rigging as I told you last
week however there are ways in which one
could argue the election is sort of
rigged against Democrats by the way one
in terms of all races is voter
suppression tactics we've talked about
curtailing early voting hours in
democratic typically lower income
typically non-white areas that's
something that hurts Democrats and helps
Republicans but we've also talked about
gerrymandering gerrymandering is
strategically drawing congressional
districts House districts that is in in
the most recent example after the 2010
census to favor Republicans so I want to
explain to you how rigged it actually is
in terms of the house in 2012 for
example Democrats received just over 50%
of the two-party vote but they won 46
percent of the seats okay so let me say
it in a different way one the majority
of the popular vote but one a minority
of the seats and a new
Washington Post model says this is on
track to happen again in 2016 now this
is partially gerrymandering the way the
districts are drawn but it's also
partially incumbency bias Pat we know
that when you have more incumbents that
by definition gives you an advantage and
also the fact that Democratic voters are
more concentrated in urban centers so
you will get some big Democratic wins in
cities but you'll still get more
districts where Republicans win where
they're more spread out in more rural
areas but gerrymandering is it's very
fair to say hey this election is rigged
but not the way Trump is talking about
and there's going to be some discrepancy
because the average congressional
district represents about 700,000 people
right some states don't even have that
number but I mean in 2014
Democrats got 1.3 million more votes
than Republicans I still had a loss in
the house so really there has to be some
kind of bipartisan commission or this
has to be settled by the courts we have
to get rid of this whole redistricting
done by state legislatures the political
redistricting is a disaster and to give
you just the numbers before I move on to
that the Republican Party holds a 30
seat majority in the house and the the
the odds that the Democrats would be
able to take that over aren't huge there
are 37 competitive districts remaining
17 of those are toss-ups 10 favored
Democrats and 10 lean Republican so it's
going to be very very tough in the house
now what about this redistricting as Pat
is talking about the political
redistricting the most recent
redistricting was done after the 2010
census every 10 years we have a census
after that you re district that's the
way it's done based on changes in
population republicans drew 193 house
districts by themselves after 2010
democrats drew 44 house districts after
the last census so what can be done this
is something that progressives can work
on during a Hillary Clinton term if we
get one again Hillary Clinton winning
not the victory the opportunity the next
census is in 2020 and
then redistricting will be done Hillary
Clinton in the White House won't
necessarily change the redistricting
process but it's an opportunity to push
for change it sounds lame right it's
Borak David redistricting if Hillary
Clinton wins this is so important and
when I talk to people I can tell their
eyes glaze over and they don't get it
but you have to care about this you can
call your state legislators you can tell
them you want a fair redistricting
process we have now a few years before
the 2020 census to demand and propose
fair redistricting measures and
additionally this is why the Supreme
Court is so important right there's
still the potential potential for
partisan gerrymandering to be ruled
unconstitutional with five Democratic
justices five more liberal justices I
guess is the way we should say is since
they're officially nonpartisan it's not
outside the realm of possibility that
with Hillary Clinton choosing the next
couple or three Supreme Court justices
that we would actually see this
political gerrymandering ruled
unconstitutional one example of what can
be done and Pat alluded to this
California voters passed a law which
established an independent bipartisan
Commission of citizens and it empowered
them to actually solicit voter input and
redraw districts lawmakers in California
in 2010 were stripped of their authority
over redistricting and that is
absolutely huge now you would think wait
well hold on let me think about this
Republicans are the party of small
government right so if politicians don't
have to be the ones drawing the
districts that's a duty best left for
someone other than politicians well no
Republicans seem to not care about small
government when it comes to the process
of drawing districts this is yet another
reason we cannot let Donald Trump win
and appoint Supreme Court justices I
don't get it Pat how to get people to
care about this I'm trying so hard this
is so huge but it is boring isn't it it
is boring but I mean it's it's a very
important topic because right now we
have politics
politicians choosing their constituency
where it should be the other way around
we should be voting for them no doubt
about it and that's why a lot of them
are fighting like hell Republicans even
if they dislike Trump because they know
that between Trump clearly taking
completely fabricated right-wing
positions on social issues and
gerrymandering and the Supreme Court
that they need to prevent a Hillary
Clinton presidency yes I admit Hillary
Clinton is not very progressive but
there's a reason that most Republicans
not all as we've talked about but most
Republicans even though they dislike
Trump are still going to vote for him
because they recognize the systemic
danger that another Democrat twelve
straight years of Democrats in the White
House represents for them you've got a
vote on November 8th let's take a break
Omaha Steaks sent me a great package of
steaks and it was fantastic as some of
the audience knows my girlfriend is
pescetarian so I invited over some of my
meat eating friends and we used my new
grill that I finally got now that it's
almost fall and everybody loved it it
was terrific
I kind of rather grill in the fall than
summer just less oppressively hot and
the limited time family grill pack that
Omaha Steaks is offering for just $49.99
is a really great way to do it you will
get two filet mignons
to top sirloins for boneless pork chops
for chicken fried steaks a 12 ounce
package of all beef meatballs for Omaha
Steaks
burgers for gourmet jumbo Franks a 16
ounce package of Omaha Steakhouse fries
for caramel apple tartlets Omaha Steaks
seasoning and for additional Omaha
Steaks
burgers and just for my listeners Omaha
Steaks is offering all of this for only
$49.99 this is a huge savings go to
Omaha Steaks dot-com enter my code
Pakman in the search bar and add the
family grill pack to your cart do not
miss this deal visit Omaha Steaks comm
and enter my code Pakman in the search
bar to get over
gourmet items for $49.99